a beautiful finish to be sure
yesterday's victory was quite dominant
with the white pieces again you had the
white pieces and this time you decided
i'm not going to play e4 let's go back
to the one that served you well knight
f3 how did that work out this time well
i have 100 score with night after i
think it's my best opening so far
uh she just got into really bad time
troubles i think when you have that
little time any position is tough to
play
and then obviously okay like rook c6
rook city that you went for it it's just
looking for some kind of activity after
just like shuffling for a while
it looked like she actually just
blundered in this position an unusual
blender to be short looks like after
takes uh allowing takes you had this
beautiful knight e1 and suddenly the
rook is getting mated yeah when i went
to a5 i saw this and i thought she'll
probably go for it because it feels like
she was looking for activity getting a
bit impatient
so
i guess a bit of a triumph
indeed a study like trap uh your score
is not what you were hoping for as far
as the beginning of the tournament but
it seems that you picked up the pace and
is doing quite well of late
i think i'm at 50
i mean okay considering how i started
this is a pretty decent result you saw
how carissa did in the tournament what's
your impression she beat four former
champions won five in a row just one of
the given that you played in a lot of
championships one of the all-time great
performances in the tournament she
clinched already yes she has oh okay no
i thought she played really well she's
definitely deserve a champion i think
she's the best player here
so
i it's not surprising at all
all right well thanks for sharing your
thoughts and good luck in your last game
thank you thank you tata good luck
indeed as